you're listening to episode 14 of
storycast 21 i'm jane secker
in march 2003 less than two years after
the 9 11 attacks the u.s led military
coalition set about toppling the then
iraqi dictator saddam hussein
long seen as a destabilizing influence
in the middle east saddam hussein's
invasion of kuwait in 1990 brought about
the first gulf war with a u.s led
coalition
this time he stood accused of amassing
weapons of mass destruction and having
ties with the islamic terror group
al-qaeda
among those involved in the ground
invasion was an idealistic u.s marine
who would soon find himself at the
center of one of this century's most
iconic moments
this is
taking down saddam
where you were earlier at the palestine
hotel you hear me david can you tell us
the name of the round i can hear you but
my name is david chater i was just
asking you to tell us the name of the
roundabout where you are on the 9th of
april 2003
i was
the sky correspondent embedded
in baghdad this is the roundabout let me
just show you around a bit um
if the camera the ward had been going on
something like
21 days
when the coalition forces crossed the
borders
into iraq coming from both the north and
the south side the front line is
squeezing in around us and the so is the
sense of danger
but the war came about because both tony
blair the british prime minister and
george bush the american president at
the time
had decided that saddam hussein the
dictator of iraq
had built up an arsenal of weapons of
mass destruction he is without any
question
still trying to develop that
chemical biological potentially nuclear
capability
and to allow him to do so without any
letter hindrance just to say we can
carry on and do it i think would be
irresponsible look i would never say he
came to power in 1979
it was a destabilizing influence the uh
iraqi dictator in the central part of
the middle east
there was no real indication that there
were large stockpiles of weapons of mass
destruction but i think the momentum of
the military buildup was such
that
the attempt to oust saddam hussein was
not going to be prevented in any way
this is the hotel that was hit by the
tank shell
[Music]
if you
go carry on up this way and follow me
we've seen the 810
tank busters
an extraordinary plane that growls that
comes in and
scatters machine gun shots
that's how i knew
that we could expect the marines at any
moment
[Music]
my name is miles hill
from
oklahoma a small town called pauls
valley
i served with the united states marine
corps as an infantry machine gunner
i was riding on the back of an armored
troop transport
there were 13 of us packed inside this
thing
pushing
from the border of kuwait iraq to
baghdad
i
felt called to join the military i had
great grandparents who had fought in
world war ii a great grandparent that
had fought
in korea
and there was a lineage
of
military history
there was nothing that i could see would
be
a greater honor to myself than joining
that organization and participating
with
such a historic unit
as a 19 year old
i wish i could tell you that i have a
better understanding of the geopolitical
structure
but what i knew then was
a dictator who had oppressed his people
for more than three decades in
through violent oppression
our orders were very general and they
were to
push forward into the city against all
resistance
and
secure the entire city
a few of us exchanged letters
to our families that we gave to our
friends in case we were to die that day
our responsibility was to send those
letters off as a final you know final
letter
they had prepped us and told us this
would be the bloodiest urban battle of
marine corps history
and they were trying to get us ready for
what they expected to be extremely heavy
resistance upon entering the city
so death was
death was something on everyone's mind
david we're just trying to work out the
geography exactly where you are you say
you've moved position from uh where you
were earlier at the palestine hotel i
was
asked if i wanted to uh you know drop my
pen and head out of the country i said
no yeah you're coming and going i guess
but
most of the other colleagues i've been
working with in sky
took up the offer
and so essentially i was there
very much on my own
in this mosque is where we saw some
fedeen taking up position with
kalashnikovs and rocket-propelled
grenades
on april the 9th the first thing we all
noticed was there was nobody there
absolutely gone every single minder was
no longer with us
and
it was exhilarating at the same time
very frightening just down there past
the statue of president salam hussein is
where the marines
with any luck are pushing forward
towards us but uh
that's all i know
the amtrak's went as fast as they could
go we were moving at a really quick
speed
i was sitting on the top with my machine
gun
it was kind of cool out so the heat from
the engine was bubbling up through
the port we were standing out of
were super high alert your heart was
pumping
then as we began to enter into
actually cross the threshold from
the uncivilized part of baghdad into the
structural part of baghdad
there were skirmishes along the way
we're standing there looking out with
our equipment
wondering which way they come in which
direction
and then across the roundabout suddenly
you started hearing the tanks
and then the whole line
swept in to the roundabout
there's the statue of president adam
hussein and there the american troops
rolling in past it that is a real within
maybe
20 30 minutes of just pushing hard
through the city
all of a sudden we were there
looking at the tower of saddam
children beginning to move into the
streets along with the journalists the
residents don't quite know what to think
yet they haven't started coming out but
those tanks now parked in the road
reporters started coming out of
the square became packed it was just
a throng of people
nobody really knew what to expect
and then as it began to shift through
excitement uh the reporters and sky news
in particular
began to
speak with
different people on the interviews
what's your name mate
jimenez good to see you
and so we were told to
stay on top
and to watch for
snipers on balconies rooftops windows
and to watch for any people within the
crowd who weren't behaving or acting
sort of suspicious
in the context of the behavior of the
other people you see a tank's taken up
position uh at the very corner of the
bank the uh troops are deploying to the
side
keep coming they had their guns at the
ready they had their weapons and
ammunition they were still looking
around expecting at any moment to be
fired but there are a few rounds still
going off we have to be careful
uh but as you can see the uh
the marines taking up tactical position
here on the eastern bank of the tigris
they're certainly they were young they
were obviously been through
a hell of an experience just to get to
where they were on the square
what's your name you're going out to
american house oh my name timothy funk
united states marine corps lenny good to
see you look there was one guy so let's
join this
i was talking to and he was kneeling
down in
establishing a firing position you're
live on sky news right now how's it been
coming in
uh it's been pretty good coming in here
as a matter of fact is this it
yeah this is just about it you've got
nothing else to really take let's hope
i think that summed it up for me all
they do is shoot at us drop their
weapons and run they take off their
uniforms and then they go back to their
lives so
the tanks and the amtraks and the other
mechanized infantry were all
circled around
the large tower of saddam standing
saluting in the center
and it was a
very palpable
very high tension
[Music]
you could feel the electricity
just
emanating off of this crap
we're just making some technical
adjustments here so uh bear with me
we've seen the locals throwing shoes at
the statue of saddam hussein in the
center of the square here very much a
sign people started throwing their
their sandals their shoes at the tower
which moment though the statue of course
in the middle east is a sign of great
disrespect
people searched around its base smashing
its marble plinth with sledgehammers
and i knew then
that we were
right there at the cusp of
a global historic event that we were
witnessing it and participating
i think you can see that's an american
marine right at the top there
putting a flag in american stars and
stripe over the face of the iraqi
strongman the iraq dictator whose statue
is about to be toppled by the u.s
marines
and
within short order within one or two
minutes an iraqi flag had been passed
and that flag was then wrapped around
the head of saddam
and people were
cheering and shouting and celebrating
then the i think there was some sort of
engineering battalion or something
that came in along with the marines
and they decided to give some help
to the uh the crowds
the engineers
on that
tank
on that tank the toe tank
they drug a chain up
and they begin anchoring that chain
around the neck of the tower
his statute but at last the the symbol
of dictatorship saddam hussein himself
the most ubiquitous site here you see
him everywhere he stares out of you from
street corners he waves uh above you and
every statue in every square well here's
one we're going to see for
as they began to pull this vehicle away
you can hear the snapping of the metal
and the
twisting and folding of the rebar that
was holding the that bronze statue
and that whole tower just came right
down
now the crowds will surge forward and
try and trample him take anything they
can kick him and and attack him in any
way they can an extraordinary side
[Applause]
i understood
this was a huge deal that that symbolic
gesture of the tower fallen
represented much more than a statue
following it was the end of a regime it
was a turning point and
the timeline and the history of these
people's lives and of their country
all this
feeling surging out was electrifying
feeling of freedom after so many weeks
of warfare and so many years and decades
of repression
there was no plan b in the uh washington
or
uk plans for what they did
after the fall of saddam hussein
at some stage it was thought you know
maybe they'd never find him but of
course they did
they put him on trial and they hanged
him
senior political sources are saying that
justice has at last been done
the disaster for the people of iraq
and for baghdad
became a civil war
it may have been a while but the people
of baghdad know only too well when
they're under siege
it was sheer anarchy and the uh 60 of
the population are shia they owe their
allegiance to
iran
that was bound to open up wounds wounds
that's never been healed and outside in
the real world iraq's worst day in a
long long time is unfolding
there was no coherent
system of iraqi government
that was able to take the strain in any
way
this was the foreign ministry after a
huge truck bomb exploded what did the
american victory
actually achieve
it came just minutes after a similar
bombing outside the finance it's still
a source of instability great
instability
great suffering for the iraqi population
imagine the impact of this in any other
city a coordinated series of attacks on
this scene no 19 i thought we were
bringing
the freedom and the democracy that as i
envisioned it as a 19 year old
devastating building and so it was a
sense of pride there was also a huge
sense of accomplishment because i had my
entire life dreamt of being part of the
marine corps
[Music]
an experience that
very few people
would ever be able to empathize with or
understand
so it's something that
i will always reflect on with
positivity
but as i get older and have become more
educated
i
studied physics at the university of
texas
and learned software programming
it's certainly
a more subjective happiness and not
objective it's just a few weeks since
american forces withdrew from urban
areas they are stressful memories they
will always be with me
but at the same time the other things
that you've covered as a journalist and
as a war correspondent they're still
with me too
i could go on and on but i mean
what hasn't changed is that
politics is still using warfare
and that means in a way that it's a
journalist
we failed we're not stopping it
no matter how
awful the scenes are that we
that we show the world
nothing is changing
[Music]
iraqi sources estimate that the death
toll as a result of the invasion of iraq
subsequent insurgency and civil war has
resulted in more than 200 000 deaths
in 2021 iraq remains a country gripped
by unrest
taking down saddam was written and
produced by rob mulhern with recordings
by tom gillespie for more information go
to sky news dot com forward slash
storycast 21
next time a former raf test pilot goes
where no britain has gone before
my spacewalk was on the 15th of january
in 2016.
we actually spent the whole morning
preparing for us baseball for me it was
the view of earth that motivated me
[Music]
you